we hired a gentleman to do our taxes in
March of this year and we ended up
hiring him to do financial planning for
us as well and after hiring him to do
that we discovered that he had filed
bankruptcy twice and had been sued for
writing a bad check we have discussed
this with him what did he say he says
that we don't understand what it's like
to run our own business
um and just basically was you know he
was very rude about it and said his
business would go on with or without us
o uh I want my money back I am leaving I
don't care about the bankruptcy with
your butt I don't want to work with
you right and he you don't get to be
rude to me about this